selden was a vain glorious fraud and yet
brother
and yet
a bow incapable of bending will
eventually break
hey guys pete here today i thought i'd
look at some of the promo stuff apple tv
plus put out ahead of the foundation
finale and talk about some of the
ongoing mysteries in the show there's a
finale trailer which had some new
footage mixed in with stuff we've
already seen and a sneak peek clip from
episode 10 that features brother day
addressing the brother dawn situation
what's interesting about these is that
they hint at a big shift in thinking for
the genetic dynasty but the way it's
being presented makes me more than a
little suspicious so we'll talk about
that and what other questions might get
answered in the finale and which ones
might not right after this quick spoiler
warning if you're not caught up with the
foundation series through episode 9. or
you don't want to see things from
episode 10 then this video won't be for
you and with that out of the way let's
get into it
the finale for the first season of
foundation is titled the leap and we
have an episode summary that reads an
unexpected ally helps salvor broker an
alliance a confrontation between the
brothers leads to unthinkable
consequences the first part of that
seems to be referring to harry selden
who we saw show up at the end of the
last episode the second part seems to be
related to the official sneak peek video
where we see brother dawn talking from
the throne about his experience on the
maiden since brother dawn is standing in
front of him it appears that he's
delivering his decision about how to
deal with the fact that he's been
altered and is no longer a perfect copy
of cleon the first he says while he was
away he had much time to reflect on
their dynasty he met pilgrims who worked
their whole lives just to walk a spiral
of salt in hopes that they might be
granted a vision before they die how the
dynasty was challenged by halima saying
that a soul incapable of change is
doomed to stagnation and how harry
seldon prophesies something similar
which you gotta love brother dusk's
response to when he says that seldom was
a vainglorious fraud it seems like he's
still salty that harry came to
prominence during his reign and brother
dave responds to him by saying a bow and
capable of bending will eventually break
which i mean that sounds like he's
interested in changing things up it
makes it seem as though his trip and
pilgrimage have helped him see the light
that maybe this whole genetic dynasty
forever thing isn't the best course of
action and in the new trailer we see him
flipping out in a rage smashing the
glass case that holds cli on the first
body he's literally smashing the genetic
dynasty or at least the genetic material
that they're drawn from he's just
smashing the case so i guess it might
not have any real effect on the original
inside but again this looks to reinforce
the idea that day is moving away from
the idea of the genetic dynasty as i
mentioned in the opening though this
does seem suspicious to me for a couple
of reasons first the dynasty is going to
fall one way or another according to
psycho history so it doesn't seem likely
that they'll turn things around briefly
just to have it collapse down the road i
expect that the empire will be in
decline and generally make bad decisions
until it no longer exists
then there's just the fact that they're
making it look like that's what's going
to happen because i don't think there
will be a rehabilitation for the cleons
it just makes it feel like this is a
setup for a twist i wish i had something
a little more solid to add to that but
there's not really any other footage of
them in the trailer other than day
screaming no in the throne room and
that's out of context he could be
yelling about anything as far as the
mystery of what they'll do with dawn
this does hint that they may not kill
him but that doesn't necessarily mean
that they would let him go on to take
his place on the middle throne either
and just to address it because i saw a
lot of people asking about it in the
comments i do think this is the altered
dawn there was a theory that they might
be switched during the raid and that
dusk brought the wrong one back and i
get the point about the nanobots it does
seem odd that they showed them healing
his arm a couple of minutes before that
but if you re-watch the scene it doesn't
look possible for there to be a switch
one of the first soldiers through the
window goes straight for the altar dawn
and grabs him holding him by the window
until the end of the shootout so i'll be
curious to see how that all plays out
beyond that there's just a couple of
other new clips in the video brother
dave with azora in the garden she looks
like she's been imprisoned and
story-wise if she can't give them
something to catch the people
responsible for what happened then what
exactly would she be able to offer them
she was complicit in the conspiracy she
was caught red-handed and so i don't
imagine this character is long for the
world and on top of that he does the
little hand gesture thing with his
fingers and it all adds up to what looks
like a death sentence to me then there's
this shot of hugo on the invictus again
that was in the saga featurette looking
at this now we can see rowan and the
thespian leader behind him and can
imagine that this is after the skirmish
at the vault it looks like they were
able to stop the jumps that the invictus
was doing but it's hard to say what's
happening in this particular shot then
there are a few different looks of gayle
on cinex but they don't really give much
away in the first one you can see that
she's made it to the surface safely and
unsurprisingly the water level did rise
everything looked somewhat underwater we
saw her entering the atmosphere in the
cryo pot and it does sort of look like
she's stranded there alone now in
another shot we see her dive into the
water which seems to be tied to the shot
of her swimming from the featurette
trailer so i suppose she'll probably
find something underneath the water but
at this point it's pretty much anybody's
guess as far as the big questions from
the series going into the finale after
what happened with dawn it seems even
more likely that the star bridge was
part of a coordinated attack but with so
much others but as i said in my last
video with so many other things to tie
up in this last episode i kind of doubt
that we're gonna get an answer to who's
behind that in the first season this
seems like something that's going to be
ongoing i feel the same way about what's
going on with gail as far as her being
able to feel the future in my last book
the show video i talked about how it's
getting harder to understand what the
second character that's wrapped up in
that story is so i'm just hoping we'll
get some kind of idea of what she's
doing there in the future remember over
130 years is gonna pass before she gets
to synax and i'm just hoping for some
hints as to what her story is developing
into
the vault was one of the big questions
throughout the season and we sort of
know what's going on there but in the
finale i expect to learn a lot more
about how that got there and how the
show version of harry intends to use
that alongside the development of the
foundation on terminus i saw there was
questions about whether harry is real or
if he's a projection i'm firmly in the
camp of projection i'm just not sure if
it's the same as what we saw on the
raven or not specifically in the show
part of harry's creating the narrative
was to die to help to motivate the
original settlers when they first got to
terminus i feel like most of the ideas
i've read about him managing to heal
himself or something similar on the way
to terminus are all a pretty big stretch
i'm guessing what he told gail was true
and part of that uploading of his
consciousness involves appearing at the
vault and i'm looking forward to find
out more about that before the season
ends and then the last remaining big
mystery is what's going on with
demerszel based on what happened with
her and halima it looks like the cleons
have altered her in some way where her
primary directive is to protect the
dynasty not any one of them as
individuals but the dynasty as a whole
as far as i can tell and like the
conspiracy with the star bridge and
brother dawn i feel like this is not
something we're going to get the answer
to by the end of this season and one of
the conversations i read with david
goyer the show runner he said that we
were going to get some of the prequels
in season two so i'm hoping there will
get a better idea of how she became the
character that she is in the tv show how
she ended up to be such an integral part
of this dynasty and then maybe what that
might mean in relation to the fact that
it is coming to an end and i think
that's about it as far as what i wanted
to say about the finale and that seems
like a good place to leave things let me
know in the comments what you're hoping
to see in the finale what questions you
have what questions you hope they'll
answer and what you're hoping that
they'll cover in the next season please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon